私はじめしゃちょー
昨日11月の25日にようやく
チャンネル登録者数が970万人を突破し
ました
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
本当にありがとうございます
youtube を始めて9年9年目えー
なんですけれども
a
あと
30万人まず30万人でチャンネル登録者
数が僕の長年の目標である1000万人に
到達するわけなんですけれども
まず今
この動画を見てくださっているチャンネル
登録をしてくださっているいつもじゃなく
てもいいですたまにでもいいので弾み社長
見てくださっている皆様本当にここまで
ついてきてくれてありがとう
心から感謝しております本当に心から感謝
していますしこれからも私は
youtube を頑張っていきたいと
思っているんですけれども結構僕
かっこつけの部分があってあんまり人に
媚びたり誰かにお願いすることがあまり
なくて結構クールぶっ
って言うんですよ自分の中ではダサいと
思ってるからクールぶってるんでしょう
けど本当に心の底から今の想いを
皆さんにお伝えするのであれば
とっても1000万人にしたいですもう
本当に行きたい
[音楽]
月内ぷで車
月にプレッシャーなんですよ天下創世記
カッコつけてさあ1000万にまで
がんばるぞ覆っていたんですけどちょっと
怖いですね肇社長のチャンネルのことだけ
ずっとやってればいいんですけどそういう
わけでもなく
私社長業をやってて今もこの新緑撮ってる
んですけども今日も朝からずっと会議が
ありました午前中は別の仕事が開業して
p 午前中は別の仕事な感じしてそれが
終わってお昼には会社の売上をすっかりだ
してなんかそれ証明書作んなきゃいけなく
て所有やり取りをしねえなら郵便局行っ
たりそれが終わって今この新居でまだまだ
全然設備が整っていないのでたくさんの
スタッフや餃子の方おうちにお呼びして
どうしていくかこの家の照明のどうするか
とか形をどう押せるかと壁紙をどうするか
とかいろんな話をしているなんか今言った
ことほぼメインチャンネルに関係ないわけ
じゃないですかそういうほんとね肇社長の
3寝るにはまあ直接的に関係ない部分で
やらなければいけないことがやりたいこと
があっ今やりたいことはめちゃん得なん
ですけどやらなければいけないことが
たくさんあってその中で今一瞬万人いき
たいなと思っているわけなんですいると
思うもう
ごめん何言いたいかわからもう自分でを何
だかわかんないんですけどとりあえず触っ
ていますでしょうか本当に心から
1000万人用実態そして今図1月の後半
でしょもう目標として
でもなぁもう表を立てるとさあ達成でき
なかったときショックだから俺目標立て
ないように来てきた人間なんですけども
ちょっと行きたすぎてる
掲げさせてください年内に
1000万人
いきたいですそう月
正直年第2戦までいきたいと思っています
もうほんとに
頑張りますよ
俺頑張るよ好きな動画をのほほんととルっ
ていうのは大事だけどちょっと1000万
にまではただ無けど僕も頑張りますし
チャンネル登録してくれてる皆さん今動画
を見てくださる皆さんの力もかりたいです
ぜひ
チャンネル登録してくださいよろしくお
願いしますチャンネル登録をしてくださっ
ているあなた本当にありがとうございます
ぜひお父様お母様
兄弟
じいちゃんばあちゃん
彼氏からぞ
めこ
肇社長のチャンネル登録をお願いしたい
です
お願いしますそして
チャンネル登録をしていない方チャンネル
登録をしないでこの動画を見てくださって
いる方是非チャンネル登録よろしくお願い
します北
かっこ付き人間だねぇ
あんまりこういうお願いは今までしても
なかったんですけれども
動画皆様の力をお借りして
そして僕自身は頑張るので一緒に
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録者数
1000万人
目指したいです年代女性
イジェマンに入れてああああああ
[音楽]
なんでお願いしてもきっとなんで私部は俺
もメリットないやろって思う方が
いらっしゃると思うのでちょっと
1000万人入った時に俺がやることの
公約をここで掲げさせてくださいまず街で
僕とすれ違ったら神対応しますなんでもし
ますも僕だっても何でもしますもう
チューチューとかちょっとアレですけど
結構見かけると強いとか言われるんです
けども神のような太陽そして私にはこの今
無限のお菓子がありますのですれ違った
廊下仕上げます